ik denk dat dit weer 1 stap verder is
weer 1 extra boost voor het vrouwenvoetbal
als je ergens de focus op legt
wat aandacht krijgt groeit
ik denk dat dat heel belangrijk is
als je 1 team dedicated kan laten trainen
kan betalen zodat ze geen baan ernaast hoeven
te hebben en zich kunnen richten op de ontwikkeling
dat dat al 1 heel eind op weg helpt
Marieke visser mag dan zelf geen prof zijn
HEB je dit dat gebeurt nooit of niet
toch Wil ze de allereerste
profvoetbalclub van Nederland
oprichten die zich alleen Richt op vrouwen
hier in het olympisch stadion genaamd hera
hera is de godin
in de uit de griekse mythologie van de olympusberg
en het staat ook voor de vrouwelijkheid
kijk er is al heel veel veranderd hè
dus ik kon niet dromen van 1 prof carrière
of ik had geen vrouwelijke rolmodellen
die HEB je nu wel
gisteren gezien
Ajax
haalt gewoon de kwartfinale van de champions league
er liggen gewoon 35.000 mensen in arena
dus dat is echt 1 geweldige ontwikkeling
over 10 jaar moet hera united
als het aan deze vrouwen ligt
de champions league winnen